- This is awesome.
Let me get my angle.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Gary] You're my
fucking idol, Gary.
I just found you last night.
(group laughter)
The competition
for that idol spot
must've not been that tough.
Hey Mumoya.
I'm great, Mom.
How are you?
("Goals" by Cartel)
I'm in Belgium.
Know what I've
been doing on Facebook?
Did you hear?
I've been converting my videos
into other languages so now
people who only speak Russian
can watch the videos and see
them in Russian.
They can (speaking
Russian) in Russian.
Hello.
I had to stay up so late.
So I'm on from 3 to 4?
- [Sam] Yes, 3 to 4 and then
you have the book signing.
- Uh-huh.
- [Sam] You'll do that on stage.
- And that's gonna
take a good hour, right?
- [Sam] We're gonna do
that in a half an hour.
- No selfies.
Yeah, we do.
What time is dinner?
- [Sam] We leave here at 7.
- Yep.
- [Sam] We're there at 7:15.
- Maybe 10.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- 10 to 11.
Alright Belgium, you won.
Alright Belgium,
I have good news.
We're gonna do a meet up.
He gave me permission.
DRock, gave me permission.
So we're doing it. 10 o'clock.
10 P.M. tonight.
Details coming shortly.
Will announce
location at 7:30, right?
I'm so bad at,
(crashing sound) oh!
Shit.
- Wow, that was.
- You didn't catch that.
(group laughter)
That was literally
the best thing that's
happened in 168
episodes or whatever we're at.
163, you missed it.
Good morning, east coast.
Sorry if I woke
you up west coast.
We're very well into
our day here in Belgium.
Doing a meet up tonight.
Say that, I like that.
- [Sam] Antwerpen.
- [Gary] Antwerpen
tonight 10 P.M. Belgium.
Pass this on, tag in the
comments all of your Belgian
friends and your
western European friends.
Getting focused here in Belgium.
Really excited about this event.
Longtime friend,
we've known each other.
What, six years?
- Yes.
- Seven?
- Seven.
Ten, that was 2006.
- No, no, I
wasn't at that one, no.
- You were there.
It was a snowy one.
- I don't think it was six.
- We'll find it out.
- Let's make a bet.
- What's the bet?
- $400,000 cash.
- Okay, perfect.
(group laughter)
- It can't be 'cause I started
Wine Library TV February 2006.
- Okay.
- So at minimum, it's 2008.
Minimum and it's probably 2009.
Believe it.
- Okay. Yeah?
But then I will owe you a lot.
- Euros, by the way.
(group laughter)
Yeah, just getting
focused. Getting ready.
I'm in an
interesting zone lately.
I think the last two talks I've
given in Canada and in Ireland
maybe I need to start
talking outside the U.S.
I think I found a new cadence.
This one should be fun 'cause
my friend here has very much
adapted into the thesis that
I've been talking about for the
last decade and has made
some noise in this market.
This market's
different, obviously.
You know, the Snapchats and
Instagrams of the world are at
the cusp, just emerging.
Twitter has not been
able to grab a foothold here.
It is a Facebook environment but
as we were yapping incredible
amounts of direct mail
investment which is crazy when
Facebook is so good at and that.
So we'll go there.
I'm gonna probably
do quite a bit of Q&amp;A.
And so, the last couple talks
have been very entrepreneur,
very philosophical, very
emotional intelligence very much
works for, what is that?
- [Sam] 2010.
- 2010.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, €400,000 yeah.
(group laughter)
Yeah, so we'll
see where it goes.
I think this one will go
a little bit more tactical.
The details of marketing more so
than kind of the philosophical
places I've been able to take
the last couple talks which will
get more tactical
and it's great, right?
That is in itself clouds
and dirt and so we'll see
where we want to go.
This is a perfect example of
where I want to do more Q&amp;A
'cause I want to be able to
answer a very direct question to
the audience and so it's a
smaller group which also lends
itself to an
intimacy that I enjoy.
It's so funny for me how much
I enjoy both 18,000 people in
Lisbon and 10 people in a
conference room like we did
yesterday in Ireland before
the main stage and everything
in between and
this is in between.
It's a warm crowd.
And so, I mean warm in the fact
that they have a lot of emotion
and relationship to him.
He has that for me so
it should be really good,
really great day here.
And gonna do a meet up
later which is exciting.
They've really put me to work.
Let me sleep a little bit but
that made me put me to work so
this isn't my normal
one hour in and out.
They've got seven to ten
fucking different events.
Sign books.
Library! Thank you so much.
What's your name?
Good. Makes me so happy.
Oh, I love it.
DRock, get in here.
Enjoying it?
- [Man] Absolutely.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Woman] So nice
to meet you, Gary.
- What's up vlog?
- [Woman 2] Thanks,
it's been enormous change.
- Separate sponsors.
- [Man 2] In
Belgium we have a saying,
I don't know if it's in English.
The high trees
catch the most wind.
- Hmmm, I love it.
And I will be until I die.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I will always innovate.
I have too much
confidence to worry about
whatever people think.
All the upside
is being a pioneer.
I want to be the highest
tree with the heaviest wind.
(audience applause)
€400,000.
Hey guys.
Yeah, thank you for having me.
What I don't understand, I don't
care if I'm right or wrong,
I'm just blown away that
you're willing to not find out.
We just sit with our
thoughts and theories of
what's tried and true.
Let me tell you something, what
got you here today is not gonna
get you to the next place.
And we sit in theory and we sit
in romance and we sit in how,
you know how many people in this
room make business decisions on
how they wish the
world was working?
The market is always right
not your fucking ego
and I got nothing but ego.
But when it comes to the
market, I only have humility.
The market is always right.
And we sit in ivory towers
thinking we're super fucking
smart and we disrespect
the market every day and
that's why we lose.
In last year's fiscal year
96% of the
Fortune 500 companies in
the world lost market share.
They lost market share because
they're marketing like it's
2005, they're
marketing like it's 1997,
they're
marketing like it's 1984.
That's why they
lost market share.
And I know this because there's
only one other time that we have
seen this big of businesses lose
this much global market share.
It was the late '40s and early
'50s when the world transitioned
from radio to television.
My friends, we are transitioning
from television to this.
It's already happened.
I've been here for a long time.
I implore you to join me.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
("Still Waiting" by Jura Kez)
Which one do you like the best?
Forehead, left side
or across the face?
(Gary laughs)
Just completely crushed it.
It's like slayed it in Belgium.
This guy slayed it.
More than this guy
and more than this guy.
I'm so competitive
for no reason.
These are such nice guys
and they're like right here,
I'm like,
"You're such a good man.
"You're my best
friend," and then I'm like,
"Fuck you, I'm the best."
By the way, most your
clients agree with you.
Like in their brains, they know
what's going on in the world.
It's just that their
modeling mix internally or their
reporting internally doesn't
justify the spend with you guys
and more importantly, there's a
dirty little secret that isn't
talked about enough which is
that marketing takes the credit
and is to blame for business
results often when it has
nothing to do with the business.
And so, they're scared.
So the answer is he, unless you
got the balls to pull it off,
needs to go to the
CEO or the board and
get it pushed down from the top.
You need protection to innovate.
That's it.
No different than the answer
I gave the kid that sitting in
your seat, like, I wish I
could give you better answer
but that's it.
Either the most senior person
gives you the air cover to get
it done or you wait and
in between you find the little
scraps of opportunities
that you guys have found.
Just like me.
You need examples, you know.
For example,
you need to put your money
where your mouth is.
You're getting bigger, maybe
you go to a local business.
Maybe they're a friend or
relative of one of you guys and
maybe you don't charge them.
Maybe you put up the money.
Maybe you put up
$25,000 for the pizza shop,
do it, record it, show them.
One step backwards,
three steps forward.
It's always the same thing.
Pictures, videos,
words, sounds until we die.
Until the robots take over.
Where is what changes.
80 years ago,
100 years ago people said
you're not being social.
You don't use a telephone.
You go to the man's house and
you shake his hand and you sit
down and you talk.
People were upset
when letters were invented.
They were.
You're supposed to go
over to their house and
draw on their cave.
(group laughter)
From 16 to 23,
I always had $1,000 on me.
Always.
- [DRock] Why?
- I didn't have an ATM card.
I'm old.
No, no and I'm a businessman.
You never know when you're going
to walk into a situation where
I needed to buy
something for $500.
I wasn't a normal kid, right?
I was doing business so I might
go to Toys "R" Us and they might
have all the Power Rangers
and I'm gonna need cash.
- Now, now?
- Uh-huh.
It's a real pleasure,
we'll talk later.
- [Man 3] We'll
have dinner together.
- Yeah, I'm looking forward to.
I'm big on sales,
in general, I'm,
for me personally, and this is
not a tried and true answer.
For me.
I love people that
sold stuff in their life.
There's something consistent
about it that's really worked
out for me in the last 20 years.
And they can be tech-nerdy, you
know the kids I like coming up
the game would rip music from
Napster and put it on CDs and
sell it in school.
So it was a little tech,
it was a little product, right?
I was baseball
cards and lemonade.
Some people
were candy, you know?
So I like sales.
I try to figure out as hard core
as I can do they need to do this
because they can't breathe if
they did anything else or are
they doing it because they think
there's more money in it or
because it's cool now.
I think that 95% of the startup
founders that I meet are doing
it the other two things.
They're either doing because
they think the money is there
'cause they get seduced by the
exits they read about or because
it's now cool to
be a startup founder.
So I hate the
current state of startup.
Hate it.
I've not been investing at
all for last year and a half.
Nothing.
I made a couple big
investments in things
that are really involved in.
But the kind of stuff
you guys are mainly doing,
I'm not even taking meetings.
Because I feel like we
have the greatest era of
fake entrepreneurship ever.
In the U.S. it
just became so big and
powerful and popular everybody
did it and in other places
it was good for the country,
the region, it was
the right thing to do
which were both true.
The problem is it brings a lot
of people into the game that
aren't meant to be.
So my biggest thing
that I'm looking for the best
entrepreneur and founder is are
they an entrepreneur and founder
or are they acting like one?
And that's too hard.
And unlike the advice that
I gave downstairs about well,
hire and fire.
You can't unfire
$100,000 investment.
You know?
And so, I think that I look
for people that are driven,
patient and not fancy.
The amount of people that are
founders of companies who go
skiing on the weekend.
Who go to every
marketing meet up event.
Who take selfies
with micro celebrities.
We're in such a bullshit era.
Basically club promoters have
taken over entrepreneurship.
("Marvellissss"
by Notion Beats)
It's the truth.
And the reason there's giggles
and head nods is we know it.
Just became cool.
Document over create.
My point on creating content is
instead of trying to think what
you make, just document
everything you're doing.
If you, do you know that two
or three of you if you just
documented the journey of
figuring this out that people
would watch your video on
YouTube every day of you trying
figure out the school system
and that in itself is what would
build your business.
It's a story, it's the
journey of an entrepreneur.
The legacy that I'm
creating with DailyVee, fuck.
You know how cool that's gonna
be when there's 10 years worth
of my every day?
Big day. Big day.
- [DRock] Great day.
- Great day, right?
- Great day in Belgium.
Especially if I
pull off very big things.
I would love, you know how fun
it would be to watch the three
years before
Drake became famous,
everything he did.
You know how
fascinating that is.
And by the way, even if it
never changed your business,
do you know how much fun it
would be for your granddaughter
to watch you do it.
Really, think about life.
You know
inspiring that would be.
She'd be like damn,
grandma was a hustler.
(group laughter)
I want to be
one too. No, really.
Right.
You know how much fun it would
be for me right now to see my
dad making $2 an hour in 1979.
Waking up at 4:30, driving
working 15 hours in a liquor
store and then coming back.
That's cool.
I don't think we
think long term enough.
What it really means.
You know, I look at
stuff now and I'm like oh man,
I was so young.
Oh shit, I was pretty fat.
You know, it's cool.
That's why I do it.
- [Sam] The reality that you're
in yourselves makes it so real.
- [Gary] I think
everything about me is
pulling it in opposite directions.
I'm the most inspirational
and the most practical.
You know, I'm in it.
(inaudible) It's my life.
- [Sam] The priest was here.
There's the skull.
- [Gary] It's in,
this is so awesome.
It's unbelievably cool.
So modern, so rad, I'm excited.
I'm gonna eat
everything in sight.
(group laughter)
I'm so happy
Jordan's not here.
(group laughter)
Alright, I'm gonna
make sure I have no fires
for three minutes, then
I'm gonna do the call and
then we can really hang.
I just hate when
I'm out of commission.
- Charge your phone, no?
- I need to charge it
but I'll get that from DRock.
("Marvellissss" by
Notion Beats)
Hey Snapchat.
Here's where the
meet up's happening.
This fancy restaurant, this
grassy knoll right near it.
Here I am.
Next picture.
I do a call-in show,
I said a lot of
entrepreneurs like to
read books, come to
conferences, have meetings,
but they don't want to do.
I said it reminds me of the guy
who wants to play tennis and
instead of practicing what he
does is he goes to the sporting
goods store and he
buys the best sneakers,
he buys
Roger Federer's headband,
he buys the best tennis racket.
Brand new shorts and
then he goes on the court
and he loses 6-0.
That's what I see with
a lot of entrepreneurs.
They've watched all my
videos, read all your books,
they've done all the courses,
they don't want to do the work.
When you look at the guys and
girls that are great tennis
players they spent everyday of
their childhood playing tennis.
- [Man 4] No other way.
- There's no other way.
- [Woman 3] So what you're
saying is they guys who are
looking at your videos are
not real entrepreneurs.
- I'm saying that the ones.
- [Man 5] I never watch them.
(group laughter)
- Here's what I'll say,
here's what I'll say.
The ones that only watch them
and never do are not and there's
a lot of people that do that.
They get the feeling
from me, and that's enough.
My best days are when I'm
reading my Instagram comments
and people are like,
"This is my last video,
I'm ready to go."
And I love it.
Not good for me following
count, not good for my views,
the best for my heart.
'Cause there's
always somebody else.
Which is why I spend a lot of
time trying to get people to
build practical businesses
because there's a lot of people
- [Man 18] I would like
to try to take a gap year.
There's not a lot that can
build a billion dollar company.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- And so, I'm trying to push the
practicality of entrepreneurship
and startup and it's working.
You saw that
kid today who said,
"Hey, you helped me.
"I was gonna try
to build Facebook,
"now I've got
this good business."
It's exciting.
There's no feeling,
you know it's funny,
I can go close a
$4 million deal with
Kellogg's or IBM, fine.
I come home and I get an email
from a kid who tells me there's
no better feeling than that.
That's legacy.
I always knew how to make money.
That's nothing new.
The legacy of
impacting people that's new.
That's exciting.
That's hearing,
that kid would've failed.
Now maybe he won't.
Not only will he then feel the
benefits but his children will.
That's impact.
- I started
working out. (laughs)
- It's good, man.
(crowd cheering)
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary, Gary!
- How's everybody?
Good?
(crowd cheers)
Alright, let's do it.
- [Man 7] How's the food?
- Food was
fucking ridiculously good.
(group laughter)
Alright, here's my concept for
this so I can get through this.
Let's first do selfies and
signed books and then we can do
questions because otherwise
people would have to wait four
or five hours.
I've done this before.
So let's first do the photos and
things of that nature then
I'll try to answer
questions if I can.
Where is DRock?
- DRock's over there.
- [Gary] Oh, hi DRock.
Awesome, real pleasure.
- [Man 8] Who's the
best NBA player ever?
- [Gary] Who's the
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- Patrick Ewing.
You're not recording.
(crowd laughter)
How long'd that take you?
- [Man 9] An hour.
Two hours.
- [Man 10] I took 3 hours.
- Yeah.
- Thanks man.
- You're welcome, man.
Thanks for coming.
Reverse engineer yourself.
Don't try to be somebody else.
Not for your parents,
not for me,
not for him, for yourself.
- Thank you, Gary.
- [Gary] You got it.
Fuck man.
(group laughter)
Lots of pens, lots of pens.
- [Man 11] You're the one that
made me shift towards gratitude
in my business.
And--
- [Gary] Funny thing happens
when you make that move.
- [Man 11] True, right.
- Yeah.
You know, all these
things are switches.
Everybody wants
these little things.
They're binary.
You're either on or you're off.
- [Man 11] Yep.
- There's no half-pregnant.
- [Man 11] The process.
- The process. Love it.
- [Man 12] I really want to work
for you but my question is the
only thing that I'm missing
is a good financial base.
- Yep.
- [Man 12] I know how to get it
but how can I work in that way
where I still have
something to say in my own idea
the best possible way?
- [Gary] Well, if you don't have
the money and if you raise the
money you don't have the say,
then you have to wait until you
have the money to have the say.
- [Man 12] That's the
best and only way, you think?
- It's the only way
if you want to have say.
Unless you decide this
idea's worth you learning from.
The biggest problem everybody
here is gonna make is they think
their current idea
is the end all, be all.
A lot of your businesses and
ideas are stepping stones.
- [Man 12] Okay.
- [Gary] So maybe it's
better for you to not have say,
learn what's good,
learn what's bad.
You're a young man.
You know what's great
about being a businessman?
Is you don't retire
at 31 like an athlete.
You play forever.
So instead of waiting until you
make the money to have control
maybe it's better
to not have control,
you learn, it sucks 'cause
you don't have
control but you learn.
Maybe you'll make some money and
then you can take the money and
go do your next thing.
You're always gonna have ideas.
This isn't your first idea.
- [Man 12] That's
true, that's true.
- Got it? Don't fall in
love with an idea.
- [Man 12] Okay, exactly.
Thank you, man.
- You're welcome.
- [Man 13] Gary?
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Man 13] Can I
ask you a question?
- [Gary] Yes but we
need to do, we're getting,
this is what always happens.
Let me bang out a little bit
more but I will answer it,
I promise you.
- [Man 13] Yes.
- [Gary] This is what you make?
- [Man 14] That's her product,
and she's doing the hustle.
- [Gary] Love it.
Just a happy family.
Cousin Gary in town.
- [Man 15] With the
man here, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Gary] We're together.
With all our friends.
Execution's the game.
- [Man 15] Yeah, man.
- [Gary] Ideas are
shit without execution.
Real pleasure.
- [Man 15] Of course.
- [Gary] Good, man.
How are you?
- [Man 16] I want to say to
you that if today I stand here,
it's because of one guy who is
behind you who listened to what
you had said that you
have to cut friends from
your inner circle.
- [Gary] Yes.
- To succeed.
- Yes.
- And today I'm able to achieve
greatness because I will show
him you do not
have friends to make it.
- I love it, man.
Well good.
- And may I have a picture?
- Yes, sir. Respect.
- Thanks for
replying to me on Twitter.
- [Gary] My pleasure.
Find a way.
Thank you, man.
Too many people try
to make a narrative.
The only narrative that
works is your true narrative.
So many people here fronting as
experts or as coaches and making
stuff happen, you're aspiring.
You're through the process.
Document your, your best story
that will get more people to buy
more jewelry than anything is
that you guys come out and say
we're just starting.
We don't know shit.
We just know that we want to
put this out in the world.
People will relate to that
more than you saying we're this,
we're that. Got it?
- [Woman 4] Yeah.
- The truth always wins.
- [Woman 4] Okay.
- It might not be
winning this moment,
this month, this year but
it always wins in the end.
You understand?
- [Woman 4] Yeah.
- Look, people's mouths are
way ahead and ambitions are way
ahead of their actions.
Everybody's talking shit but
people aren't putting the work.
So you just need,
by the way, by the way,--
- If that's your goal.
- Exactly.
Do you know how great it is
to make $100,000 a year and be
happy and go on vacation and
love your life, it's great.
Everybody now thinks
they have to build Facebook.
It's so stupid.
- Exactly.
- You just need
to know yourself.
- And can you start at 28?
- You can start at 58.
- And building
million dollar businesses?
- Of course.
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
the guy was 75
years old when he started.
- Perfect.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, hug, man.
(group cheering)
- [Man 17] The greatest person
I've ever met on
this fucking planet.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- [Man 17] For real,
like look what you've done.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- It's fucking amazing.
I look forward to
actually like grow up.
To follow you
the next five, ten,
twenty years
it's fucking insane.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Thank you, brother.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
If I grew up in the era that
you're growing up in this shit
would've been
over a long time ago.
(group laughter)
If I had eBay and
Shopify and Google and
fucking the internet,
I didn't have shit.
There was no computers.
Fucking went to
the store, bought shit,
went to the flea market
on Saturday and sold it.
Like you guys have
it so good, so easy.
You have it so good, so easy
that it tricks
you that it's easy.
It's so good and so
easy that you're getting
tricked that it's easy.
It's not easy.
Yo, you ready for this?
- Yeah.
- Hustle you mother fucker.
(group laughter)
- [Man 18] Business on the
side or take a gap year and
try to launch it?
- Both work.
- [Man 18] Both?
- [Man 18] Which one is best?
- I don't know you well enough.
You know.
You know what I mean?
They both work.
Which one do you want to do?
("Still Waiting" by Jura Kez)
- So take a gap year.
- [Man 18] I'm scared.
- That's why you're asking.
- [Man 18] Yes.
Which one would you do?
- I wouldn't take either.
- [Man 18] What
would you do then?
- I can't answer that for you.
Fear is holding you back.
You know what you want to do.
The only reason you're not doing
is 'cause you're scared of doing
what you actually
want to do. Right?
- [Man 18] Yes.
- Are you scared to do it 'cause
your parents won't like it?
- [Man 18] No, my
parents actually supports me.
- Okay, so what are
you scared of? Failing?
- [Man 18] Not failing but still
being at the same place when my
friends are at the next level.
- Huge mistake.
You don't want the same
things your friends want.
- [Man 18] No.
- So why the fuck do
you care what they have?
Number one mistake so many
people make is they care about
what other people have.
I don't give a
fuck what anybody has.
If I have more, if I
have less, doesn't matter.
I worry about myself.
The fact that you're
worrying about other people's
accomplishments is
already a losing formula.
You need to get
rid of that first then
you can focus on yourself.
- [Man 18] Thank you.
You understand?
- [Man 18] Yes, I do.
- You just have to talk these
things through and when you get
to the right answer, you
answered it which I love.
- [Man 18] Yes.
- So the fact that you care that
one year later you do your thing
which you loved and you decided
you wanted to do but you weren't
successful and your friend got
a job and now he's got a little
bit more money
that that bothers you.
I built up a $45 million
business in four years and was
still paying myself $40,000.
No fancy car, no fuckin' watch,
no fucking bling bling because
I knew what I was doing it for.
I believed fully,
she's still here,
in what I was doing.
Right, you're worried about way
too many short-term goals when
your mouth says that
you want big time goals.
- [Man 18] Yes. Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Man 19] Gary?
- Yeah?
- [Man 19] Do you recommend
that you document your journey?
- Yes. Guys, the
amount of people that
are asking me questions,
dude, I'm just
gonna say it real quick.
Everybody's asking me questions
that they know the answers to.
The fact that you used the words
"document the journey"
(group laughter)
you know I believe in that.
- [Man 19] Uh-huh.
- Same with you.
Everybody,
same with a bunch,
you're all
looking for permission.
- [Man 19] I'm
afraid of documenting.
- That's it.
That's right,
everybody, it's all fear 'cause
it's a binary thing.
Once you get your mindset around
why you're doing things and that
you're doing it for
yourself it all opens up.
Both of you, back to back,
care about other people.
- [Man 19] Mhmmm.
- And that's fine.
I care, I don't want to let
my parents down but not at the
expense of my one life.
- [Man 19] Thank you very much.
- You're welcome, man.
Yeah. Cool.
Again, watch what I do.
Just don't listen, do shit.
- [Man 20] Right.
- Like when I thought
of the 60 Second Club,
I did it an hour later.
And I have a big audience.
I have a lot to lose.
- [Man 20] Mhmmm.
- Right? I have a lot to lose.
And then again, I just said it.
It's been fucking three
months, I switched back.
I'm not scared to change.
- [Man 20] Just do shit.
- Do shit.
I knew that I was a
businessman and when you guys,
most of you didn't
see this the big man that
I hugged out he saw it.
I was the wine guy.
- [Man 21] Yeah.
- I was the wine guy.
So I started making business
videos and everybody's comments
were, "Stick to wine."
"Do what you do."
"What the fuck do
you know about business?"
I had already built a business.
People didn't
even know me for that.
Just do shit.
- [Man 20] Mhmmm.
- I decided I'm gonna
start a beanie company,
I may or may not but
I'm trying to do it. Right?
- [Man 22] More, more, more.
- Remember the honey company?
Where's the honey company?
'Member for some of
you that watch #AskGaryVee?
There is no honey company.
VaynerToys failed,
there's no honey company.
I didn't get to it.
But I tried to.
I got a lot of samples,
I got a lot of data.
I'm just doing all the time.
We're ideating everyday,
making up shit on the spot.
- [Man 20] Playing around.
Testing.
- Playing, doing,
doing, doing, doing.
If one out of
30 things succeeds,
it's better than
all of the things that
you guys haven't started.
- [Man 20] Boom.
- Yeah. You got it?
Go, go do something.
(group laughter)
Dude, what the
fuck is this thing?
(group laughter)
I love the old school, my man.
Alright guys, thank
you so much for coming.
A vlog?
- Yeah.
One, the biggest value that
you can share with my viewers.
- Well what kind of
viewers are they? Youngsters?
- Youngsters like me.
People wanting
to start a business.
People who need
personal development.
- It's patience.
It's fucking patience.
It's patience.
Like all of you
want it too fast.
I'm 41 years old and
I feel like I'm seven.
Like when I was 20, when I
was 15 or 17 or 22 I thought
41-year-olds were
so fuckin' old.
They felt so old.
I wish all of you 13, 16, 19
and 24-year-olds could feel how
young I am in my soul right now.
It would change
everything you do.
You'd become dramatically more
patient which would mean that
you would make a lot
more of the successes
that you want to happen.
Most of you will lose because
you're trying to take shortcuts.
- Wow. The process.
- The process.
- [Man 23] I have a question.
- My pleasure.
And you're young.
You can make 19 mistakes
and start at 30 and
get your shit going.
- [Man 23] Thank you.
- [Gary] Lack of patience.
- [Man 23] Okay.
- Lack of patience.
That's what that ladders up to.
I'm here, I'm here.
You got it, DRock?
(crowd cheers)
Bye guys, I love you. See ya.
- I have an idea
for an application but
it's like for charity.
- Okay.
- Normally people don't
give gifts to donations.
- Yep. Gamification works.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] Charity
donations happen.
The combination of the two and
the economics around building an
actual business, the problem is
right now everybody's building
apps and they're
not building businesses.
- Mhmmm. Yeah, it's true.
- [Gary] I know.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That is what
you need to think about.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] It's the
business of apps not apps
that are businesses.
Everybody's thinking about apps.
Your app might be right.
Do you have a
sustainable business?
The economics of
the scale of what
you're building
is very difficult.
- That's true.
- [Gary] Got it?
Cool.
- Thank you for your time.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Man 24] Thank you.
You were it for me.
- [Gary] I hope so.
What's up, brother?
- [Man 25] One thing
you would have done
differently in VaynerMedia?
(Gary clicks tongue)
Zero.
(group laughter)
No regrets.
- [Gary] No regrets. None.
Let me give you
the best piece of,
I appreciate you asking that.
What value in the world does
it have to look backwards in a
world where you're gonna
make a ton more mistakes.
Do you know what I mean?
Reconciling mistakes you've made
in the past in a world where
you're gonna be making
a bunch more seems like
a waste of
energy to me. You know?
That's what, you learn from your
mistakes but like who knows if
I didn't do that,
everything's wired together.
If I didn't make that mistake
but would've lead me to that
meeting which
became my ultimate upside?
You can't unwind them.
Everybody wants to
unwind shit to tactics.
That's why I stay
so macro, got it?
- [Man 25] We're
gonna make a copy of it.
We're coming for you.
- [Gary] Awesome.
I hope so, man, do it.
My man.
- [Man 26] Thank you very much.
- [Gary] You're never
gonna beat what you copy.
(group laughter)
1:06 in the morning.
Leaving four or five
hours to the airport.
Hustled it hard in Belgium.
Brought it in Belgium.
Fuckin' brought it.
Fucking brought it.
that could make
100,000 a year in profit.